hello everyone
welcome to another episode of science
and technology q a for kids and others
and uh i see we have
all kinds of interesting questions
queued up here
let's see
there's one here from erin
can i explain neutrino messaging and
whether it's feasible to build a
neutrino messaging system or a neutrino
internet
okay well first of all i have to talk
about what neutrinos are and then we'll
get to the their potential uses okay so
what are neutrinos neutrinos are a type
of particle a little bit like electrons
or quarks
or photons
but different
and
what happened
neutrinos were originally suggested in
the 1940s i think
and first actually observed uh
in the 1950s i think
uh here's what happened
so
there's a process nuclear beta decay so
there are there are
some
elements that are radioactive there's
some uh substances like plutonium some
isotopes of uranium
these kinds of things which are
radioactive
there are that means that the nucleus of
the atom kind of spontaneously
self-destructs
after some period of time
in fact even just a single neutron if
you broke it out of an atom if it wasn't
bound in with the protons in an atomic
nucleus a single neutron will decay
after about um 15 minutes or so
and when it decays this neutron sitting
there it turns into a proton
an electron and an antineutrino
the thing about neutrinos is they're
really hard to detect
so let's talk about the decay of the
neutron the neutron which is a neutral
particle it has no electric charge
decays into a proton which has electric
charge plus one and an electron which
has electric charge minus one
and electric charge is conserved so the
neutron has charge zero it decays into
the proton charge plus one the electron
charge minus one
and that means the thing that's left
over is charge zero the new shear is
charged zero
but what was observed when people first
started looking at nuclear beta decay
they would see
things like sometimes they would just
see
um
they would they would see these
particles come out and another feature
in addition to things like charge being
conserved momentum is conserved so that
means
if you have something
that uh well you you
the the if you
if you know that um let's see if you
have some object
and it suddenly uh let's say it's a it's
a thing that's got two little pieces and
they're connected by a they have a
spring in between them and but they're
all held together and then the thing
that holds them together uh
is is detached and then they spring up
apart
okay what happens when they spring apart
is one will go in one direction and the
other will go in the other direction if
you looked at what
what the sort of the the average
position the center of mass of these two
things it would stay stationary
that that's because momentum is
conserved there's momentum associated
with the thing with one of the things
going in one direction there's momentum
associated with the other thing going
the other direction those two momenta uh
are if you sort of combine them together
you get zero moments and that's what you
have to get because that's where the
thing started is with zero momentum it
started stationary so whenever
so what people observed in these beta
decay processes was they would see
particles whizzing out in certain
directions and then they would say
what's going on because momentum is
supposed to be conserved and that means
these particles are whizzing out in
these directions but what's the thing
whizzing out in the other direction that
has a momentum going the other way that
together will make the momentum of all
these things be conserved
and um so
the um
uh the question
so a person called wolfgang paulie
uh physicist also famous for paulie's
exclusion principle in quantum mechanics
um
was uh the person who originally
suggested oh maybe there's another kind
of particle that's whizzing out in the
other direction we just can't see it
um
in the case of the decay of the neutron
it's like protons electrons they're
electrically charged you can detect
those kinds of things but this other
thing that's whizzing out in the
direction it's not electrically charged
and maybe it's really hard to detect
well turned out
neutrinos were really hard to detect
they were because they interact very
weakly with most things most of the time
a neutrino
will you have a beam of neutrinos for
example
it'll just go straight through
everything
and um
the
and what happens is
these there are different kinds of
interactions between particles basically
four basic kinds strong nuclear force
which is what holds atomic nuclei
together electromagnetism which is
associated with electric charges and
electric fields and magnetic fields and
so on um then there's this so-called
weak nuclear force
which is the thing that's associated
with nuclear beta and then there's
gravitation which is a separate story
but this weak nuclear force as its name
might suggest is quite weak
it's it's the thing and it's the only
force that a neutrino
uh kind of is sensitive to a neutrino
doesn't have electric charge so it
doesn't it doesn't subject to the
electromagnetic
electromagnetic forces
it is not a strongly interacting
particle like a proton or neutron or a
cork or something that goes in an atomic
nucleus it's just a weakly interacting
kind of thing
so
uh what actually happens well you can
have
it's kind of a rule about particle
physics and so on that if you have
something like neutron goes to proton
plus electron plus antineutrino then
it's kind of a rule that you can say a
little bit like uh
that you can kind of flip that around
and say well it's also possible that a
neutrino plus a neutron can go to a
proton plus an electron
that uh
that that's um
that's a
a general principle in particle physics
it's kind of like positive and negative
numbers if you've got a particle coming
out that's like um
a uh
you can kind of um
uh
uh you can kind of flip that around to
being like an anti-particle coming in so
to speak
so
any case you can let's say you have a
beam of neutrinos and you've got a bunch
of neutrons then you can have
an interaction with neutron plus
neutrino goes to proton plus electron
okay
so that's a kind of mechanism for
neutrinos to interact with things but it
doesn't happen a lot
the the rate at which that happens is is
very low
and um in fact
when
one feature of of that interaction is
the
as the neutrino gets to be higher and
higher energy that reaction becomes more
and more likely so if you can have a
higher energy neutrino more likely that
you'll actually see it scatter from a
new from a neutron and produce a proton
electron
um
that was something that was eventually
observed and i described a little bit
more about how that happened
in neutrinos
in in the early 1960s
so
actually maybe even slightly earlier
than that okay so let's talk about what
produces neutrinos so as i mentioned
nuclear beta decay produces neutrinos
that's something when
you
have uh
a nuclear reactor when you're producing
all sorts of different
uh you produce all sorts of radioactive
isotopes radioactive versions of
chemical elements
in a nuclear reactor and a bunch of
those
will
will undergo beta decay and produce
neutrinos kind of what happens in your
typical nuclear reactor is you're
breaking apart
things like uranium nuclei
and they'll sort of fall apart into a
lot of smaller nuclei a lot of nuclei
have lighter elements it's kind of a
random
collection of different elements that
you produce you're producing these
different isotopes isotopes are
versions of an element so they
you know you characterize an element by
the number of protons in its nucleus
which is equal to the number of
electrons that it will normally have
so you know hydrogen is one helium is
two lithium is three and so on but then
you can have in the nucleus different
numbers of neutrons and those are the
different isotopes of the elements
correspond to when you have nuclei with
different numbers of neutrons same
number of protons for a particular
element but different number of neutrons
so when in a typical nuclear reaction in
a
in a in a nuclear power station or
something you will generate some quite
random collection of different uh
isotopes of different
uh of different elements that come about
when the let's say uranium nuclei are
broken down by the process that
leads to um
that leads to power generation of
nuclear reactors
okay so you get these random collection
of isotopes and many of those isotopes
will happen to be radioactive and
they'll happen to be radioactive with
with the produce that undergo beta decay
and therefore produce neutrinos so from
your average nuclear reactor there'll be
a whole bunch of neutrinos produced
and so that's one big source of
neutrinos in fact the the first way that
neutrinos were observed
was
by having oh there's a nuclear reactor
here and somewhere quite far away
you could observe that there were
neutrinos that have been produced in
this nuclear reactor it's kind of like
nothing is being transmitted from the
nuclear reactor to the experiment you're
doing or nothing you can see is being
transmitted but somehow
that whatever is transmitted can
interact with neutrons let's say and
produce protons and electrons
so that was kind of how neutrinos were
first observed
the um was
from uh from nuclear reactors there are
other processes that produce neutrinos
that are a little bit more controlled in
terms of of the neutrinos they produce
because in a nuclear reactor the core of
the nuclear reactor just has all these
reactions happening and neutrinos are
going out in all directions from that
one way you can produce much more
organized neutrinos really a beam of
neutrinos is in a particle accelerator
you produce
uh particles called pions
so in an atomic nucleus in a first
approximation the thing that sort of
holds the protons and neutrons and so on
together is the exchange of particles
called pions
um and pions are particles about
one-tenth the mass of a proton
and when you kind of crash protons
together
hard they will kind of
you'll you'll end up producing a whole
bunch of pions
and pions are short-lived they decay in
100 millionth of a second
um the uh and it so happens that pions
the well at least the positive and
negatively charged pions
decay primarily to muons and neutrinos
and so that's muons are kind of like
heavy versions of electrons they're also
unstable they decay in about two
microseconds two millionths of a second
um they decay into electrons and a
couple of neutrinos
the pions decay into a muon and neutrino
but because
the of the way that momentum works you
can have
you have
so pions among other things are are
charged particles which means you can
direct them using magnets and things and
so that means you can kind of organize
your pions to be going in a definite
direction then they decay and they're
as they decay they produce neutrinos
neutrinos are kind of more or less going
in the direction the pions were going in
and so that's the way that you can make
kind of a beam of neutrinos
and so that's something that big
particle accelerators like fermilab and
so on people routinely make neutrino
beams by having a bunch of protons they
they turn into pions that they well as a
result of colliding with other protons
they produce pions the pions decay into
neutrinos the neutrino but the pines
have been sort of organized to go in a
different direction they decay into
neutrinos you have a beam of neutrinos
then you can sort of direct that beam of
neutrinos to then interact with more
stuff and see whether you can detect the
neutrinos because the only way you can
tell that there was a neutrino there is
by seeing it interact with things and
produce particles that you can readily
detect like protons and electrons and so
on
okay so
those are two sources of neutrinos
another source of neutrinos that was for
a long time very controversial was the
sun the sun is a great big uh example of
nuclear reactions going on
and many of those nuclear reactions
produce neutrinos
the one question is
what's the energy of those neutrinos the
most energetic neutrinos were produced
by rather obscure reaction in the sun
that's a
the sun is mostly taking hydrogen and
fusing hydrogen nuclei together to make
helium but there's a a sort of a
complicated side chain involving boron
uh
slightly heavier element that has uh um
in which the highest energy neutrinos
were produced and that reaction only was
thought to take place in the very center
of the sun
and the amount the rate at which that
reaction took place depended very
sensitively on the precise temperature
of the center of the sun it's kind of
hard to measure the temperature of the
center of the sun it's maybe i don't
know 10 million degrees or something but
it's uh
we don't get to see into the center of
the sun
one reason we don't get to see into the
center of the sun is because the light
that's coming from the center of the sun
it's like the sun is really very opaque
it's not like it's it's transparent the
outer layers are are quite transparent
and once once once produced a piece of
light near the very surface of the sun
it will just go out uh easily enough but
if you produce a photon of light in the
center of the sun it can take like a
million years to kind of gradually kind
of make its way to the surface of the
sun
so we don't get to sort of see into the
center of the sun at least not with
photons but neutrinos on the other hand
a neutrino produced in the center of the
sun the chances are it will just go
straight from where it's produced in the
center of the sun out out of the sun and
come to the earth and if we have a
neutrino detector and it so happens that
neutrino kind of ends its its life so to
speak being scattered in that neutrino
detector we get to see it and the sun is
presumably producing huge numbers of
neutrinos
because sort of every every nuclear
reaction that takes place more or less
produces some neutrinos well that's not
quite right the the many produce some
neutrinos and these ones deep in the sun
can produce high energy neutrinos
so for a while people would try to
detect neutrinos coming from the sun and
it was very mysterious because they
didn't observe any neutrinos and it's
always very suspicious when you do an
experiment and say we saw nothing that's
always uh
you know it's hard to know because it
might be that there's something wrong
with the way your experiment was set up
and that's why you saw nothing rather
than that was really nothing there
and when you do a neutrino experiment
it's a tricky business because you
basically have to
get rid of uh so
what you're looking for is something
which
uh
you see no sign of it until suddenly
inside your detector you
observe the result of scattering by the
neutrino and so people try and take
neutrino detectors and put them in
places where
all other particles would have been kind
of removed because it's underneath a
mile of rock or it's deep in the ocean
or it's underneath the the south pole
um or something like this and so there
are particular locations like the mont
blanc road tunnel is one one location
there are some deep mines
um there's some there was one attempt to
to do something in the ocean of hawaii
there's one at the south pole actually
also
where
the idea is to have your detector for
neutrinos be be so deep
uh underneath so much rock that every
other particle that might be coming
through if there was an electron a
proton and a muon or something like that
that would have long ago been been
stopped and scattered and only neutrinos
would survive and get to your detector
so okay so that that's sort of the the
um uh so so there was this big mystery
for a while that there was enough
neutrinos from the sun and people were a
little bit concerned maybe the center of
the sun has gone out
maybe it's no longer producing energy
and that would be sort of disastrous but
fortunately that didn't turn out to be
the case and it was just that the
experiments weren't being done quite the
right way
and once things were set up correctly
neutrinos from the sun were observed and
there was another tricky issue because
neutrinos there are three different
kinds of neutrinos and they react in
slightly different ways
and as neutrinos can kind of mix so you
kind of start as one kind of neutrino
end up as another kind of neutrino
that's a that's a different story to be
told but in any case the
you know first approximation neutrinos
interact very weakly
and uh go through uh huge amounts of
rock but you can if you're lucky enough
the any particular neutrino will
interact inside your detector and you'll
be able to notice that it was there
so people wondered what you could use
neutrinos for and people talked about
using neutrinos to kind of x-ray the
earth so to speak with neutrinos where
you just use neutrinos for example
coming from the sun or maybe coming from
a nuclear reactor and you could
kind of detect
those neutrinos on the other side of the
earth
but
exactly how many neutrinos you detect
could depend on what kind of rock for
example was present because certain
kinds of rock will scatter neutrinos a
bit more than other kinds
okay so
neutrino messaging we were asked about
the question would be
if
there were
uh if if we wanted to for example send a
message from one side of the earth to
the other going through the center of
the earth so normally you know the
fastest way you can get a message um
from one side of the earth to the
opposite side of the earth is to oh i
don't know send it through a fiber optic
cable or send it by radio between
satellites or something and clearly that
uh you you're having to go round the
circumference of the earth if you could
actually have something which would send
a message directly through the center of
the earth
then you save your your pi over two of
uh circumference versus
um well you'd save your your um uh yeah
your pi over two of of half
circumference versus diameter about 1.5
so you you're sort of 50 shorter to go
just through the center of the earth so
that would be sort of a win if you could
pick up neutrinos on on the other side
of the earth
but in order to make this work you have
to have a source of neutrinos that you
can switch on and off that's tough to do
because your typical nuclear reactor
doesn't just it takes a while to start
um uh to switch on it takes a while to
switch off
it's not um it's not something where you
can just say switch it on switch it off
and you can't have a big shutter that
says okay we
we drop this shutter and then we're
blocking all the neutrinos because the
whole point is very little it's very
hard to block a neutrino
so
tough to tough to sort of organize that
um we might think about you know the
extraterrestrial civilization that's uh
using neutrinos to communicate with uh
other extraterrestrial civilizations not
quite sure in kind of empty space
between stars for example you might as
well use photons of light because they
you know you can
light that comes from the the very edge
of the universe can reach us perfectly
well most light never runs into anything
coming to us from the edge of the
universe
so i'm not sure that neutrinos are a big
advantage there
um
there are big there are sources of
neutrinos
in the universe a big source of
neutrinos in the universe is supernovas
uh exploding stars and when stars
explode they are exploding because
of basically nuclear reactions that
happen and those nuclear reactions like
other kinds of nuclear reactions produce
random collections of isotopes many of
which
decay
in
produced neutrinos and many of the
nuclear reactions many of the primary
nuclear reactions
that um
[Music]
that are involved in in a supernova will
also produce neutrinos
so when there's a supernova there'll be
a burst so a supernova scar collapses
might take a few seconds to collapse um
the final part of the collapse might
take a few seconds there'll be a big
flash of light um and there'll also be a
flash of neutrinos at the same time
detecting those neutrinos will give one
information on what's happening instead
of in the center of the supernova
because neutrinos are coming all the way
from the center of the supernova whereas
whatever light is coming is coming from
the surface because the light doesn't
get through this sort of interior in the
same way so people definitely interested
in detecting bursts of neutrinos and
there's some evidence that they've been
detected from supernovas that have
happened as typically in a galaxy of our
size is about one supernova every
thousand years um and that means if we
look at a bunch of other galaxies
further away we will see supernovae with
some frequency and uh there's a question
of whether we can detect sort of
neutrino flash from those things and the
answer is yes we're sort of at the edge
of being able to detect that an
interesting question is does the flash
of light
as we detect it arrive at the same time
as the neutrino flash and the answer is
it seems yes
and that's an important thing to know
because it tells one things about what
tells one things about the uh the the
photons are presumably traveling at the
speed of light the neutrinos
the neutrinos have a very small mass
travel very close to the speed of light
but not exactly but presumably at the
speed of light and there are other
things that one can learn from looking
at neutrinos versus photons uh moving
through interstellar space
that was a much longer answer than i
expected to that that question um and uh
um
i think the answer to is it feasible to
build neutrino messaging system is no
not really not anytime soon
and you know is there a neutrino
internet operating between all the
extraterrestrial civilizations that
we've never seen any evidence of um the
answer is i think it's not not based on
the technology we know today it's not
your best source of um
uh best way to send messages i will say
that it is conceivable that there is a
much more efficient way to detect
neutrinos than we already know
i actually thought at one point in the
1980s that i might have figured out how
to make such a thing
i'm actually quite glad it didn't work
out because
one of the features of being able to
detect neutrinos
very easily is that you can detect
nuclear reactors everywhere and
particularly at that time it was a sort
of a big issue that where there were
nuclear submarines that were prowling
around the oceans
and american ones russian ones etc and
uh they were thought to be oh nobody
knows where the nuclear submarines are
but if you can detect neutrinos easily
you can just detect the neutrinos that
are coming from those nuclear submarines
um and you could find out where all of
them are and that's not necessarily a
good thing
so
the uh
and the same
uh right now one of the things that's
become popular with neutrinos is i
mentioned that neutrinos are produced by
nuclear reactors uh you can tell uh
quite a bit about uh the details of
what's sort of inside a nuclear reactor
by looking at neutrinos it produces and
so there's kind of this idea of if you
want to tell whether somebody is
operating a nuclear reactor that's just
producing electric power
versus a nuclear reactor that's being
used to make
um
kinds of isotopes that are relevant for
making bombs and things you can
potentially detect that by having sort
of a you know a neutrino detector that's
that's
you know that's not
that that's um uh i don't know some
some small distance away from the
nuclear reactor
kind of just outside the perimeter of
the facility or something you just have
this this big neutrino detector there
and then you see are there neutrinos
being produced and how many are being
produced
see it's it's pretty hard sometimes to
tell what's happening in a nuclear
reactor because nuclear reactors are all
sealed up uh partly because of
radioactivity and so on they're all
sealed up and
it takes a while to sort of
shut one down and kind of get it ready
to open it up and then then you can kind
of look inside and then you close it all
up again and then you keep running it
for for potentially years at a time
so
it's very inconvenient to say hey show
me the inside of your nuclear reactor so
if you can detect that remotely using
neutrinos it's a much better idea and
that seems like a pretty feasible thing
to do right now
okay let's see
um
well
um
question from jonas here
as a particle physics question
noting that
basically all the particle physics
experiments we've done we've done on the
earth
and there's a certain amount of gravity
on the earth
and
the question is it's a good question
i've never thought about it before
the question is how do we know that the
results we get
from those particle physics experiments
don't depend on the fact that they have
been done
in the gravity of the earth
um
that's a good question
there is
uh
i'm not sure we have terribly good
evidence about that
um
the furthest away
that we kind of get to see particle
physics happening is in cosmic rays
there are particles many produced by the
sun
some produced by various processes in
distant galaxies in many cases
that
are
accelerating particles mostly protons to
very high energies and those protons
eventually if they reach the earth
they will typically
interact in in the atmosphere and they
will produce a whole shower of particles
sometimes it's a shower of particles
that's many miles across by the time it
gets to the surface because just one
proton
50 miles up interacts with uh protons
with with
atoms in the atmosphere and there's this
whole kind of spray of particles that's
produced
called an extended air shower and these
things can there can be
thousands tens of thousands of particles
produced over a uh over an area that's
that's many miles across
so probably the furthest away kind of
particle interactions that we have
directly seen i think would be from
things like extended air showers
of cosmic ray interactions that are
happening
still in the gravity of the earth but
it's slightly weaker gravity but i don't
think we know
um in detail whether the
detailed properties of those
interactions are the same as the
detailed properties of the interactions
that we see in an ordinary particle
physics experiment on the earth's
surface
so it's a good question um
whether for example
one could expect well that there isn't a
lot of variation in the gravity of
things on the earth
um
there's
there's obviously some effect of the
gravity of the moon and the gravity of
the sun and we see that in in the
pulling the oceans up in tides and so on
but that's not a huge effect um i
suppose that one could try to measure
whether for example the um that's kind
of a funny thing to ask it's kind of
almost like um
do the particle physics experiments come
out with different results at the full
moon than at other times of the month so
to speak uh i bet nobody has ever looked
at that um i'm sure the answer is no but
i bet nobody's ever looked at it
um
the uh so one could uh let's see how
else could one figure that out
i think it's going to be quite a while
before there's a particle accelerator uh
on the moon
and uh one could ask the question i
suppose um
actually i wonder whether there's been
any particle physics experiments done
um
in
earth orbit uh
i don't think there's ever been
a certainly radioactivity has been
observed in
in uh in earth orbit where there's sort
of effectively no gravity because
there's uh ones once uh uh weightless
and sort of free fall in orbit around
around the earth um
and um
um
let me see i that that i don't think
they've been particle physical
experiments done because i don't think
there's ever been a particle accelerator
um in earth orbit
at least nothing well that might not be
quite correct
might not be quite correct i doubt
there's been a
uh that there might have been particle
accelerators in earth orbit for military
purposes
um because one of the things that
uh
is
relevant is when if you're trying to
shoot down some missile that's an
intercontinental ballistic missile for
example that's going from one continent
up into kind of low earth orbit and back
down again um if you want to kind of
shoot that down
one approach that people have considered
is particle beams
um
where you basically make a um a beam of
protons for example and you kind of
shoot it from a satellite
and try and shoot down the missile or
something using that and i think there
were definitely experiments done on
particle beam weapons like that so so
maybe that's caused that to be a
particle accelerator in earth orbit if
that happened i wonder whether anybody
looked at whether the uh probability of
interactions between protons and so on
was the same there i'm sure they assumed
it was the same as on on the surface of
the earth
but it's a good question i i doubt
that's been looked at
um
let's see
oh there's a question here why should
gravity which is considered a very weak
force compared to others have any
significant effect on particle physics
experiments
um one wouldn't expect it to have one
absolutely wouldn't expect it to have
but but you know the nature of
experimental science is it's sometimes
worth doing experiments even when you're
pretty sure you know what the answer
should be
because it it could be the case that
that there's some tiny effect that's
never been noticed where once you see
that effect you say aha that explains
all these other kinds of things but yes
based on standard models of of physics
one would expect that effect to be very
small
now an interesting question
is
in the
oh it's an interesting question in this
in a strong gravitational field near a
space-time singularity of the kind that
you would find like in the center of a
black hole for example
what effect would that have on particle
interactions so let's say for example
that you are you have you have the
singularity in space time that means
among other things that uh any any
object uh just like
the uh
uh the moon has a gravitational effect
on the earth it has a tidal effect on
the earth it pulls the pieces of the
earth that are closer to the moon it
pulls them a little bit more towards the
moon
than
it
than the center of the earth and it
pulls the things further away from the
moon a little bit less far hard than it
pulls the center of the earth and so
that means that there's this tidal
deformation of the earth that the earth
kind of has pulled uh the the outwards
towards the moon and it kind of bulges
and and outwards away from the moon so
so you know if the earth starts as a
sphere it it deforms slightly to become
something that is more like an ellipsoid
um where it's been kind of um
as a result of the of of the gravity of
the moon
and
when that's applied to the liquid oceans
that has the effect of pulling up the
ocean that's close to the moon and also
letting to be sort of uh up
the the ocean that's far from the moon
and the oceans that are sort of on the
two sides are are not uh not sort of uh
pulled pulled up and let to go let's go
in the opposite direction
and so that kind of tidal deformation
named that way because it's what causes
the tides is something you expect in
general um as a result of gravity and
the earth by the way also has solid
tides it's slightly even the solid
structure of the earth is slightly
deformed by the gravity of the moon
when you are approaching a singularity
in space time where the gravity is
infinitely large
then the uh that effect that tidal
deformation effect becomes similarly
eventually infinitely large so that
means that if you had a an object
you know a planet let's say that was
getting very close to this singularity
in spacetime you would end up with the
planet will be very deformed very
tidally deformed um and eventually sort
of uh the the term that's that's used in
the business is spaghettified it will be
turned into that it would just sort of
shredded into sort of spaghetti-like um
structures
okay so the question that one might have
is what would
that kind of affect what effect would
that kind of thing have
on for example
particle
interactions between particles
um
i have to believe let me think about
this for a second
um
well i'm sure there's some effect
okay so
it's a little hard to understand what
effect that would have on particles that
are supposed to be perfectly
that are supposed to be sort of perfect
geometrical points like things like
electrons and quarks
in our model of physics they're not
perfect geometrical points and so
there'll be a slightly different effect
there but a question that one might have
is um
for something like a proton which is
very small by our standards but quite
large compared to
uh
you know a proton is a is a is a big
hefty thing with definite size um even
though it's um it's not uh not even it's
it's known for a long time not to be
just a perfect geometrical point with no
extent
so a proton would presumably get
spaghettified so to speak by
the effect of strong gravity
and
certainly the interaction between
protons the probability of two protons
kind of interacting would be changed by
that
um and let's see one could probably work
out
uh in a first approximation i think it
will be changed um
as a result of literally the the you
know
without gravity the the proton might act
like a sphere and then there's some
chance of two spheres hitting um and if
the thing has been turned into this kind
of uh very elongated shape the
probabilities will change somewhat um
and i think i could imagine how to
compute that
uh because it's related to
various kinds of electromagnetic
scattering theory in any case the um
there might be some other effects there
let me think
um
yeah let's see
in
um
yeah i i think
they'll be okay so so there's an analog
of this
boy okay i'm descending rather deep into
into rather technical physics here but
um
i think
yes what one would expect to happen
uh
well basic bottom line is there
definitely would be an effect on
particle interactions from the very
strong gravity very close to a
space-time singularity we are very far
away from a space-time singularity the
the um the the the sort of
the the the difference of space
from being perfectly
flat in a sense for us
is it's incredibly close to being
perfectly flat whereas in near the
singularity it's sort of infinitely
curved so there's a huge difference
between what we can observe on earth and
what we would observe near a black hole
but i think that that um uh uh there
would be an effect from that which would
be interesting to work out and actually
it's not a um not impossible that that's
an effect where there will be a
significant difference between the what
we now believe about physics with our
model of physics involving uh discrete
structure of space time and so on and
what uh sort of older theories of of
physics have suggested so it might be an
interesting
interesting thing to work out
uh
let's
see um
gosh there's a question from ww here
relating to thermodynamics
how can we detect to remove the impact
of refrigeration and air conditioning
indoors on outdoor global temperature
and is it significant
um
i don't know the the numbers for this
but
the
uh
well let's see maybe i could try to
explain how refrigeration works
um i think i explained that once before
let me not do that here because i'm
pretty sure i explained that once before
so we should just find a reference to
where i where i did that before
um
let's see
oh there's another one of these uh kind
of could we do this
a question from asa can we build a giant
magnifying glass and put it in orbit to
create a death ray
well hmm
i think uh so
what that i think is referring to is
if you were to
concentrate the light of the sun
for example as you can do with a
magnifying glass for example on on you
know on a sunny day you have a
magnifying glass
you concentrate
the light from the sun into a single
spot
um and you can like burn a piece of
paper or something um particularly if
the paper is black so that it absorbs
more more
uh
more light
um and therefore the um the the light
will heat it up more more easily but the
question would be if you had a giant
magnifying glass because you have it in
earth orbit and you kind of align it
properly and you've got the sun over
here you've got magnifying glass here
and you've got something on the surface
of the earth and you'd be heating it up
and maybe heating up some water or
something and maybe deriving power from
it or some such other thing
um i think that
there are many problems with this
picture
um
the uh
well first point is
uh
by the time
let's see
um
at some point by the time you've
concentrated enough energy
in one place
you will
i think
good question
um okay so so normally light goes
through the air and you have more
intense light more intense light goes
through the air so you have light
consists of a whole bunch of photons and
when the light is more intense when you
you know the brightness of the of your
you have a brighter bulb or something
like this all you're doing is just have
more and more and more photons
um
there the question is
is there a point
yes that there's eventually a point
at which any material so in a vacuum you
can just put more and more and more more
photons through a vacuum and nothing
much will happen to the vacuum the
photons are all independently going
through the vacuum there's a tiny tiny
effect called light by light scattering
where photons actually interact with
each other but that's an absolutely tiny
effect
um so for the most part you just more
photons they just go through a vacuum
now if you have
uh the air
for example or if you have a piece of
glass
if you put
um
if you put enough photons through it
uh eventually
it will
saturate because what's happening is
when photons are going through something
like glass
they are being absorbed by one atom by
an atom and then just a tiny time later
they're being re-emitted by that atom
and there comes a point at which you've
kind of saturated these atoms they've
all been they've all got they've all
just absorbed photons they haven't yet
emitted the photons
and
that in that situation
the you'll get kind of saturation
of um that it will no longer transmit
the photons through in the way that you
would have expected
and
eventually that would happen with
intense enough light
in the air although the intensity would
have to be incredibly high
um and probably higher even than one
would imagine from from such a setup
i think one is has a much much better
bet than having a lens in in orbit
because the lens is going to be a big
thick thing with with lots of glass in
the middle is to put a mirror in earth
orbit because with a parabolic mirror
you can have the same effect of
concentrating light except with the lens
the rays of light are going through the
lens and being concentrated on the other
side with a mirror the rays of light are
coming into the mirror and they're
bouncing back and if the mirror is in a
parabolic shape then
all the the parabolic shape is such that
when rays of light come in
parallel from the sun for example
they're all concentrated into a single
focus a single point in the center of
the parabola
and so that would be a more realistic
way to do that
um oh actually that wouldn't that
wouldn't succeed in doing what you
wanted at all because that would
concentrate all the light from the sun
at this point at the at the um
at the center of this paraboloid what
you would have to do
oh yes no this this experiment is pretty
doomed i think
because with a magnifying glass you're
always the focus the focal point for the
magnifying glass is always right below
the magnifying glass and the thicker the
magnifying glass the closer the focus
will be
um but uh uh
so what you are asking for okay so so
the case that you might be asking for is
essentially a quite thin magnifying
glass that's 100 miles away in earth
orbit that is just starting to
concentrate light
uh light rays and when it gets to a
particular point on the earth's surface
all those light rays will be
concentrated the problem is so in order
to concentrate lots of light rays you've
got to have had lots of light rays going
through the lens or hitting the mirror
that means you need a very big mirror or
very big lens that's a problem i i think
i think in the end this is kind of
doomed and i think uh the effect of the
saturation of of
uh this saturation effect from light i
think once actually that's probably
irrelevant once actually far away from
such a limit for anything one can
imagine there so i think that's that's
not a likely likely thing to be able to
do
um
let's see
um
there's a question about does a does a
magnifying glass steal energy from the
surroundings well like a when you have a
magnifying glass and you're using it to
burn something with light from the sun
no it's just taking light from the sun
uh well what's what's happening is that
light from the sun would have just those
parallel rays of light would have just
fallen separately on your piece of paper
but what you're doing with the
magnifying glass is you're concentrating
all those light rays which would have
fallen on different parts of the piece
of paper you're concentrating them so
that they all fall on that single spot
in the middle of a piece of paper and
and that's it's because you're
concentrating all that light
all the energy associated with that
light just in that one place that you
would heat that place up
all right maybe one one or two more
and then i need to
uh
go here well let's see there's one here
quite different um
um
let's do that this time
um
[Music]
okay there's a question from proots
are there technologies that were very
fragile and unreliable 50 to 100 years
ago but are extremely reliable and
widely used today and then are there
early stage technologies that have the
potential to be widely used 50 years
from now
well the most obvious technology that
was fragile 50 years ago and is very
widely used today
is transmitting data
through
uh
through various communication lines
back
uh like 40 years ago
it was hard to transmit data at more
than about 30 characters per second but
like for example in this live stream i'm
doing right now
we're transmitting data at um uh
you know about hundreds of thousands of
times that rate um and it's all working
just fine
and
it's sort of interesting how one got
from
there's a you know the the most the
earliest telephones you know when
alexander graham bell was inventing the
telephone one of the things that was an
important point was just how cruddy
could the sound you got out of a
telephone be
and yet have people at the other end
still be understand be able to
understand what was said
and so in the very earliest telephones
from a hundred and uh
220 or so years ago
the um a little bit more than that
actually the um uh
the um
uh they were probably by our current
standards they were just um uh
you know they could you could hear
something but it was really cruddy
telegraphs had existed for quite a long
time for like 60 years or something
before the telephone in a telegraph
you're just
you know you just got this key and
you're just doing a long press or a
short press dots and dashes most code
all those kinds of things and it was
possible to transmit
uh kind of well enough to be able to
tell up there was a that was a dot that
was a dash
many years before it was possible to
transmit something which was
intelligible speech and then still
before then that then then to get to the
point where you could transmit video the
first kind of demo video phones existed
in the 1950s and it took until well
basically about 10 years ago before sort
of video
phone like technology was robust enough
that it could be widely used so that's a
i think that's a pretty obvious example
of um where
there's technology that um was kind of
uh sort of there were signs of it you
could say from the 18 early 1800s from
telegraphs and things there were signs
that that was possible but getting to
the point where oh we're transmitting
video routinely all the time that was a
long span of time
the fax machine which is now kind of
almost a thing of the past where you
transmit uh you know today it would be
like
scan a page turn it into digital data uh
send it over
uh you know over over a network and then
at the other end make a printout of that
page that was fax machine technology and
the earliest fax machines were made in
the mid-1800s people had uh ways of uh
people imagine that you would kind of um
do something where your uh your your
you're sending something which is
ultimately a picture and you're sending
it in dots and dashes of a telegraph
but to make that practical took a lot
longer and um that was that was a
another example of something where you
could sort of see that it was coming but
it took a very long time
i think you know space travel is another
thing where you know there are examples
of it from long ago
and it's just on the sort of uh just
sort of advancing to the point where
it's becoming uh more routine now
i think the same
computers another good example
where the earliest computers from the
1940s
were well that kind of by the 1960s
there were practical systems but they
were very very big
the idea that you would just sort of
have a computer in your pocket that was
something that took many more years to
to come to fruition
and i think um um
it's something where uh if we look at
things today
you know there are some inexorable kinds
of of of progress
one thing you know there was a time when
uh if you were listening to things you
would have
you couldn't really get a representation
of sound that was as if you were really
there
in other words our
ears
with their you know whatever it is 50
000 nerve fibers in the auditory nerve
and so on they were what
we could hear from a sound
when we're right in the room there
was
much better than what you could get
from a record player or a
tape cassette player or something like
this
but there came a time probably 15 20
years ago now when
uh computer
sending digital audio by computer got to
the point where we can transmit data and
sort of recreate the audio at the other
end that's as good as what we can
transmit through our auditory nerve and
it's at the point where the audio is
sort of as if you were there
we're not quite there with video we will
be that's an inexorable thing and you
know their issues the video like our
eyes there's a lot that we see kind of
out of the out of the side of our visual
field um and
most displays you know it's a display
right in front of you that's where you
know virtual reality displays sort of
the one of the bigger effects
is that you kind of get to see a a
larger angle so it's kind of you're
you're seeing some things in peripheral
vision as well as in kind of straight
ahead vision
and so that that's that's one type of
thing which i think is sort of
inexorable i think that
there will probably be slow progress in
things but i don't know how well it will
really work in kind of the um oh well
another piece of inexorable progress
will be
things like augmented reality being able
to have a display that's not only a
great big display but also something
which is kind of like i could i could
have a little tiny display thing in my
glasses and i could be overlaying um
some you know i wouldn't need to have a
a sort of a physical computer display
out there in the world i could just have
something that's being displayed sort of
in my glasses or maybe something that's
just painting light directly onto the
retina at the back of my eye from some
little device uh in my glasses and
that's something which is you know that
they've been demos of that kind of
technology for a long long long time
that will eventually become routine and
it will routinely be the case that as
you're sort of wandering around you'll
see these little displays of interesting
random things based on your geolocation
and things like that
there are other kinds of
things like data transmission
uh radio based data transmission you
know 5g is is presumably coming um that
will be higher rates of data
transmission but there
is
no obvious
uh
i mean there's some some sort of
theoretical upper limits to the data
transmission rates but they keep on
being little tricks to more or less get
around those
in certain cases and i think one can
expect that and the most important way
of getting around them which is what 5g
is using among other things is instead
of having one antenna that's just
broadcasting lots of stuff you know one
cell phone tower that's kind of
broadcasting to a big area for every
cell phone you have much more local
broadcasts so that you only have to deal
with uh getting you only need to have
your radio be be in the small area and
that's um uh and so then you can kind of
deal with having more cell phones there
and so on and more data being
transmitted at faster rates
to more cell phones and all those kinds
of things so i think that will be a
thing that where there's just a lot more
kind of um
uh data
that's um that's coming through there i
mean there are just tons of things i
mean there are tons of things in
medicine
where you know we have the beginnings of
sort of you know the 3d printable organ
type thing we have the beginnings of
being able to have kind of molecular
scale computers basically that operate
like the kinds of things that happen uh
biologically in our cells but being able
to program those things so that instead
of just having you know a drug molecule
that goes to a particular place
and uh
and has a sort of chemical um
and chemically does what it does you can
have something where there's essentially
something the size of a molecule that is
able to
uh kind of go to some place in the body
and be doing sort of uh and be actually
kind of computing what to do that's
that's uh kind of a
another thing that i think we can sort
of see the early early signs of that
the early early signs of sort of
synthetic biology where we're able to
kind of create a molecular scale
biology-like thing
that works in a particular way i mean i
could i could go on at
a great length because there are just a
lot of things where one can kind of see
the beginnings of signs of things
and um uh and and you know it's going to
be a while before they can come to
fruition
i think there's a question asked here um
is there anything where the opposite has
happened
um something which is fragile today but
was stable a century ago
does technology universally get better
you know that's an interesting question
i mean people say
that oh you know this amazing sword that
was made in this very special way at
some time in the past you know nothing
like that exists today i think you know
when there are swords that were made
from metal that came from meteorites and
things that's a very rare sword that had
to be very carefully made uh very
carefully you know find the materials
for it or whatever i think it can be the
case that there are kind of lost arts
where people would do things sort of the
hand-crafted version
which existed 100 years ago nobody knows
how to do that anymore and what you get
that is sort of the machine-built
version does not have quite
the level of uh of of some kind of
adaptation to the materials and so on
that existed in the past
um i would say in terms of technology
that's been lost i mean that you know
that's a complicated issue because
there's technologies where people hope
they're lost
because
they're they they don't seem to have
they don't seem to do good stuff and
they seem to have a lot of bad
consequences too
um and i think that there are you know
there are
well we'll we'll see how many of those
there are i mean there there are
certainly things where you know some
nasty virus or something which was more
or less exterminated um it's like well
you know was it really exterminated can
you keep a little supply of it things
like this those are things that um kind
of uh uh well no we don't have any more
of that now because we really don't want
to have it more of it
um i think that um
uh trying to think of examples where
there were sort of lost arts of lost
technology that doesn't exist today
that existed in the past what kinds of
things can i think of
um yeah i mean there are
there are constantly pieces of
technology that come and don't quite
make it an example
back 40 years ago i was very briefly an
enthusiast of one-handed keyboards
okay where
often so-called chord keyboards where
you would press two buttons at the same
time to
and you could you could type in
principle very fast because you don't
have to move your fingers you're just
like well i push these two fingers or
those two fingers and you're not moving
them around
and i thought i had this whole idea that
oh it would be kind of cool you know i'm
always interested in sort of personal
efficiency kinds of things you can kind
of
walk around you can have some nice you
know i was thinking about i'd seen
virtual reality displays and things you
kind of walk around with some display
and you can just be typing uh not
looking at your fingers and typing on
this chord keyboard
i don't think people
you know do that people type on their
with their thumbs on
on cell phones and things but i just
don't think that technology which
briefly seemed to take off and then just
disappeared again don't really
completely know why
so that's sort of an example of a piece
of technology going backwards i would
say that um
there are
there are probably pieces of technology
let me think about this
um you know there there are plenty of
things where people say
uh that
piece of technology that um uh that
sort of um
is some
combustion device that kind of belches
out smoke or something oh let's not use
that anymore let's make a version that
um is much cleaner and so then that kind
of technology uh kind of disappears
um
and um
uh but but isn't it's not it's it's in
practice i mean there's there's plenty
of technology where people built it once
and people have kind of almost forgotten
how to do it i mean whether it's early
spacecraft where the plans have been
lost whether it's nuclear reactors where
people built them and that's kind of
like nobody really remembers exactly how
certain things work
um there are things like that more local
kinds of things in terms of
general classes of technology that have
been lost
um
trying to think i mean once certainly
over historical time that we know of the
antikythera device from 2000 years ago
that was kind of a clockwork computer
that wasn't sort of recreated until the
1600s that was an example of lost
technology
but i think
i'm trying to think over a 50-year span
of things i might remember that were
technologies i mean there were there'd
been plenty of medical things that have
come and gone during that period of time
and people said this is a great idea we
can cure this with this and then people
said well no you can't really it has all
kinds of you know bad effects and it's
um not uh
and so that sort of gets gets walked
back
but um i'm trying to think and um
um
[Music]
you know there are things where
there was a technology like for example
when i was a kid
one off you know i typically would write
with an ink pen that had liquid ink that
you would just fill the pen with you
know and had some elaborate plunger
system and nibs and all this kind of
thing people do that as a as a matter of
being sort of quaint and um
and kind of uh
with the gravitas of history type thing
but
that whole technology of sort of ink
ink wells and filling things with ink
and so on that technology is not really
very much with us anymore because sort
of other technology has moved on so it's
less important
um so i mean there are there are all
these kinds of things another piece of
technology i might mention
before there were electronic calculators
there had been a long process
of perfecting kind of mechanical pocket
calculators
and um
there's uh gosh what is the thing called
um
it's a little device
uh one of my kids has one of these
things that um it was exotically it was
made in liechtenstein
which was perhaps the center of the
mechanical calculator
industry for perhaps a little while i
don't know but um they're these uh these
things that are just very densely filled
with the whole thing is filled with cogs
and you turn things and you move things
and you can sort of calculate uh you can
sort of pocket calculate mechanically
that way um that's been sort of a lost
art doing that and and you know what's
funny about these lost arts is then it
turns out one day somebody needs it like
i uh one question is if you want to send
a spacecraft to the surface of venus
it's very hot there
and uh most ordinary materials just melt
metals don't necessarily melt
but computers that are based on
semiconductors semiconductors are very
sensitive to heat
and
so by the time you're at 350 degrees
centigrade or whatever the temperature
is there's no way an ordinary
semiconductor will work there so you
kind of have to have a plan b for how do
you have a computer on the surface of
venus and one of the more exotic
possibilities is well make it be a
mechanical computer
and obviously the technology of
mechanical computers is that's a lost
art but perhaps there's a use case for
it that may emerge even in the future
and um
there's a question here about what were
the next advance in microprocessors
3d lithography you know this is one of
these funny things
where
there are these it will be there in the
future
kinds of claims that exist over very
long periods of time i mean i remember
in the late 1970s people saying when you
you know microprocessors your you're
sort of designing the circuit and the
circuit is just a two-dimensional
circuit you've got little wires and
transistors and so on and they're all
just arranged in
on this chip that is a
just a two-dimensional thing i remember
people saying in the late 1970s there
will be 3d trips instead of just having
the circuit arranged on that single
surface the circuit will be arranged in
in arbitrary depth with wires going up
and down as well as
sort of left and right and so on um and
i don't think that technology it still
hasn't arrived i mean i think there are
probably issues with that technology to
do with heat generation and so on that
might be different even from the problem
of like fabricating the original circuit
but it's sort of funny to me that that's
something where people said it's almost
here now
from um uh from that long ago it is
strange that there are technologies
where you hear that for a really long
period of time like flat screen
televisions another one where one knew
they were coming for a long time before
they actually came
then there are technologies where
honestly they kind of snuck up on one
like for example drones is an example
you know the idea that you could have
kind of a quadcopter type thing you know
helicopter-like thing with four rotors
that idea certainly existed long ago and
there were test versions of that sort of
where people tried to control them back
from the 1950s and maybe even earlier um
but that technology people always said
oh well you can have a remote control
helicopter those are kind of difficult
to operate and so on and then sometime
when was it it was probably like a
little less than 10 years ago now
suddenly uh
the suddenly sort of they're burst onto
the scene
drones with four rotors and what made
that possible was having flight
controllers things which can control the
speed of the rotors based on the
orientation of the drone can do that
with sort of easily enough that you can
actually build them
into the drone so that it can control
itself so that even though there's an
instability where one side of the drone
will start going down then you make that
rotor go faster you write it and um
that's uh that's that's what makes
drones possible is the flight controller
system that exists the control system
for keeping the drone stable but that to
me it was like i didn't really expect
that it wasn't it wasn't something i
mean even though that technology sort of
precursors existed for ages i wasn't
really tracking when will we get to the
point where that's possible i mean i
suppose right now an example of that
will be is electric airplanes um you
know there will come a time
presumably when battery technology
presumably when battery technology is
good enough you might as well just
uh you know rather than than burning
fuel or something like this you might as
well just have a battery on your plane
you know uh sort of charge it up and off
your plane goes
obviously that's been possible
for um
for tiny model planes for ages but to
make a a big plane to have it work so
you can really do that in a big plane
they're are test versions of that right
now but to do that on a serious scale is
something that presumably will come
um and uh it's something where it's sort
of inexorable that that will come i mean
just like
you know people have been talking about
flying cars
since
well i remember seeing a popular
mechanics magazine that's sort of a
place where in fact i think i have one
of these uh you know the car of the
future from the 1930s i think and it's a
flying car
and it's like well we're nearly 100
years later there aren't any flying cars
and uh you know
i think it's an inexorable thing there
will eventually be flying cars
um
it's uh the question of how much people
will care about flying cars is an
interesting one it's just like people
say
uh you know at this point in this
pandemic and so on people have learned
that it's possible to do a lot more
things remotely than unexpected i had
been a remote
ceo for 30 years so it was uh um you
know i kind of already knew this
but
this question about
um
you know
how important is it that you are in a
particular place versus being just
connected how important is it that you
can take your flying car and go to such
and such a place um you know quickly is
that something you care really a lot
about or not so much about another one
of these sort of inexorable things is
supersonic planes
which again uh you know i think there's
an initiative now to try and do that
again um i think you know that's one of
these things that will eventually happen
and the reasons why it didn't happen
with concord and so on
are fairly detailed reasons having to do
with efficiency and cost
and sonic booms and making uh and sort
of the particular aerodynamics of uh
that produced shock waves that were
really loud on the ground and so on i
remember when i was a kid uh quite often
seeing concord fly over and um you know
you would didn't um and occasionally in
some sort of test situation it would it
would make a sonic boom um over over
sort of a populated area and so on and
it was pretty loud
um but you know that's that's an example
of something where with more detailed
careful technology and careful
understanding of shock fronts and so on
one can expect that that will be solved
and such things will exist
and you know i think it's kind of the
inevitable flying car so to speak is the
only thing that's hard with that kind of
technology is figuring out you know
what's the time scale and when will
things become reliable enough when will
it become easy enough to i mean it's
actually a lot easier to navigate in the
air than it is on the ground there's
much less to run into in the air and
it's much more of just well go in this
line and you know get to where you're
going um obviously if they start being a
zillion flying cars they're all kinds of
oh we've got to have all these
algorithms for avoiding other flying
cars and you know are we certain that
will work and what about if there's a a
giant um bird that's going to come and
attack your flying car and all kinds of
different different issues like that
um but uh in any case
um
let's see well i think we should
probably um
uh i'm actually i'm still i'm still um
looping a little bit on this question
about does technology universally get
better
and i'm i'm kind of wondering about some
of these things where
yeah you know there are places where
some natural material
was kind of a really good way to do
something but that natural material was
in short supply or people decided it was
a bad thing to be using that natural
resource and so let's have kind of an
artificial version instead and it wasn't
it wasn't quite as good
for one reason or another
and i think those that there are places
where sort of technology has gone
backwards for those reasons i'm trying
to think in terms of
of electronics for example
mostly that's very much gone forwards
there are some slight uh things um
but um
uh mostly that's that's a just went
forwards
i think that um um thinking about other
areas you know as i say in medicine
things tend to go forwards backwards
forwards backwards people realize oh
that wasn't such a good idea oh the
trade-offs are different and so on in um
uh
um yeah i mean there are technologies
where they appear and then they like
hovercraft they were another technology
i remember from when i was a kid that
was kind of supposed to be the future of
transportation you know
uh boats and things are a thing of the
past it's all hovercraft all the way
down um that didn't pan out
at the time don't know exactly why um
and who knows maybe that's the thing
where people will say in the future oh
that was a lost technology what a big
mistake
i'm not sure
um
anyway uh well i think we should wrap up
uh here for today
and um
thanks for joining us and um
see you again another